[Music]
citizens of the reject Nation I have an
important question for you would you
rather be a troll or would you rather
band together because you can't do both
except we're here today for trolls B
together don't ha me I was haing in
conjunction with you was a yes and also
what's your hul uh I what was your H I
was trying to yes s and it I want to
hear it again I I want to do it again no
I want to hear it
again coming from Miss raspy over here
Mak for I you're right I have no right
to make fun of anybody's voice ever Greg
what's up how are you we've watched two
of these trolls we're on the third one
it's been popular it's been requested
you feeling good about this I'm feeling
good about it I I Don't Know Jack about
it I'm assuming band together what a
great title I just put it together band
like a band and the baning to dual
meaning oh that's great that's clever
that's some good marketing I did a whole
intro about the band together yeah but I
didn't dawn on me until like oh you're a
[Music]
band uhhuh like comment subscribe let us
know what you guys thought about the
first two is this the best one so far
have we heard good things uh I don't
know I haven't looked anything up I
didn't either I heard nyn does music for
this oh yeah that's the one thing we saw
them do that they did like a hot one
thing or something for this okay that's
pretty cool thank you to prepper for
helping us edit down these videos if you
want to be the sexiest of Rejects and go
over to patreon where you can sync up
with your own copy over there Greg and
John cover several shows
exclusively with highlights of wogs she
almost did a whole one by herself she
panicked she looked down she panicked
yeah but that's okay cuz we're going to
band together now yes we are to watch
this movie before we do that do you want
to troll me for a second
uh well it's a free pass to troll uh in
three two
one pass over we're watching
it hit us with them
Tunes a long time ago in a troll land
far far away we're going to open with
girl baby baby and close with baby baby
girl wait no that doesn't sound right
it's fine open with baby baby girl close
with baby baby girl
woman okay we are going to make boy band
history tonight 51 oh how many n sing
songs do you those abs need to be
popping
baby baby baby girl woman do I really
have to keep wearing these things you do
Clay they're Thunder drawers it's
underwear but 76% more fun now let's see
those dance moves brother Rusty robot
into bro you look stress it's the first
show of the tour we have to to hit the
perfect family harmonies calm down
you're making baby Branch nervous baby
branch no no he's not allowed to be
nervous he's got to be perfect I like
how they call him baby Branch hey Branch
how you feeling I feel like I'm going to
barve
a pass out and pee your pants all at
once how' you know you got the pre-show
Jitters completely normal you want to
know what I do when I get them bar pass
out and PE pants yep I remember that I'm
with my brothers and that when we come
together there is nothing that we can't
do wow you band together no one's ever
hit the perfect family Harmony before is
it true it can shatter diamonds perfect
family Harmony we got our setup follow
my lead or maybe let's just go out there
and have fun together so much pressure
is this end sync that's what I'm
thinking must be if we can't hit the
perfect family Harmony we aren't perfect
and if we aren't perfect we're nothing
follow my lead and the harmony will
happen I don't know what any of their
voices sound like I I do but I it's
really hard to tell here spru sensitive
one it's been a while since I've seen a
boy bad
parody but it also feels like an
[Music]
homage oh this is
cool I'm digging this song yeah me
too they just did that that in sync move
so who's that maybe it's Justin Tiber
like with Voice
[Music]
modulated Greg I don't want to put you
on the spot but name one member of ins
synct that isn't JT Lance B this isn't
myo to the perfect
[Music]
harmony oh guys
guys who would be fun kind of though if
it wasn't so scary see what happens when
you don't follow my lead dude that is
exactly what happens when we follow your
lead I wonder if this is a play on real
life no then they'd be fighting with
JT dude this used to be fun now it's all
about being perfect you know what I'm
done playing the heart
drop
I quit I quit too I've had that
conversation before I'm going to find
trolls who take me seriously fine I
don't need this I'm out guys I'm going
to go hike the neverglade trail by
myself bro loan yeah that's right bro
bro going solo YOLO have a lot of these
interesting like one shot they move like
a music video like a K-pop
video it's my fault so is that one lance
we're not in sync we're not in sync Boys
to Men and now there's only one
direction for us to go the back street
back street the earring is on his right
ear which is what you do to when you're
queer and get one piercing it's time to
start a solo career what am I going to
do you are going to do the most
important thing of all you're going to
take care of
grandma this guy BR has had so much Dr
tra when you miss me you can wear this
it'll be like I'm right here with you
and when you come back we'll make our
Hideout wow is that a 10 Story water
slide yeah that's how we
shower we always thought this was
Poppy's Trilogy it's branches I'll see
you soon baby Branch BBB baby Branch
what's up baby I think it is they talked
about solo careers name drop Back Street
Boys in sync Boys to Men One Direction I
think this is a play on real life in
some way yeah but he wasn't the baby of
the I think he wanted to break away
right so it's a little different but yes
when art imitates life imitating art
imitating
life sup poppy are you all right you're
smiling and crying at the same time it
kind of looks like it's hurting your
face no I guess I'm just missing my um
Grandma I was just listening to some of
her old records why are you missing them
now no way I love R oh my God she
doesn't know it's him I
mean kind of seems like there's
something you're not telling me yep what
a woman always knows
if you're having feelings you can talk
about them with I love her oh hey look
at the time we're going to be late to
the Royal Wedding you don't have a watch
let's go get married Branch I I mean
Bridget and Crystal Mary please explain
all men right now what do you mean oh
look at the time yeah we avoid and we
throw ourselves into work just wanted
you to say
it oh yeah you know the number one cause
of depression is Nostalgia it can't be
true com don't stop it now don't stop it
now don't stop it now no a longing for
the past is a leading cause that's what
you mean
okay hey look at the
colors I love how this introduces kids
of this generation to such great music
and this is the version they will listen
to yeah but I don't care at least
they'll know it no
lie all people
she's like okay you can avoid this for
now babe not
later I'll give you an hour we got to
see these guys from the kingdom from the
first movie this is a Trilogy coming
full circle we boy that was a crazy B
forie Cloud guy don't feel so good Cloud
gu back they're all coming
back baby how you
feeling
oh my God cool mash up look at you tiny
diamond oh my God the diamond man's back
I want to be like him I'm the cutest
little flower man but tiny you're only a
month old still I'm just a little
baby talking I don't know why I like him
so much Daddy I'm a man now not a little
child what do you think it's read like
in the script
probably just Bonkers yeah we
are is true you got to like really
visually map it
out the colors are just always so great
in this I like this first 10 minutes
more than the first 10 minutes of
Charles World Tour already more
emotionally invested in
it well I don't know what the emotional
conflict is going to be yet like he
wants to find his brothers
again um I like all the trolls movies so
far and this is an iconic outfit yes
balloon Queen poppy thank you so much
for being my Made of Honor a I love you
like a sister probably I don't have a
sister so I wouldn't know which is fine
it's something I'm coming to terms with
slowly uh poy can we maybe unpack the
sister thing after the V I guess that's
the bee story well maybe just the fact
that he has brothers that she doesn't
know about and she's going to be like I
always wanted a sister you have all
these brothers you don't even see M good
prediction
will poppy and Branch get married in
this one we are gathered here today to
celebrate the Sweet Love Falling in Love
is Easy I didn't find it easy at all
let's unpack that stop the wedding what
who dare protest is this bad timing I'm
just trying to find a troll name baby
Branch uh you're making a mistake
stranger that looks similar to me
there's no Branch here you're not a
branch anymore you more like a trunk
Chunk in the trunk ow whoa
inappropriate you got heavy oh my God
horse oh God twoe hes hey this is why
you stopped the wedding oh he just was
coming to find his he didn't mean to
yeah you're right I'm Branch's brother
what drama cor
me corn
me V me leaving the room dad did you
know about this what would I know about
secret family
members does she have a secret sister
what did we know about I feel like
that's a reference to something previous
brozone we were just listening to them
yeah brozone wait wait wait wait wait
don't tell me um okay well you're not
the heart throb well that's your
opinion you're John Dory the leader the
old one the old one if your branch is
bro then that means that all the other
bro Zone Bros are branches Bros
too you come from wealth Branch Branch
was in the band all right no way which
one was he bitty
B A faletto made of gold but that's all
in the past because they stopped being
my brothers the day they walked out on
me and never came they did abandon him I
did come back but no one was there it
wasn't until I heard about you saving
the world from The Rock apocalypse that
I realize you were even still alive
trolls World Tour I need something it's
about Floyd he's in Danger Man
cool transition Floyd is Lance I have no
idea I got a letter from him Dear John
Dory I'm being held against my will by
Superstars velvet and veneer come to
mount raes at once and bring our
brothers the sensitive one I didn't know
where any of you were so I went to mount
Rous so must be
Lance who mount rageous looks
contagious looks like a rage Fest mine
was better mine was was way better Mine
rhy Mine mine's more accurate cuz it's
not contagious I found where this velvet
and veneer were performing it's good
back and forth we're having right now I
am
courageous made of these oh this is a
really appropriate song for children to
disagree
wow look this must be one of the most
covered songs ever yeah
[Music]
so they left the band to become action
heroes he's like a
spy and there was Floyd they're keeping
him
hostage oh this this one isn't Lance
velvet and veneer are giant pop obsessed
succubi with no talent and they've been
stealing mine that's even worse than
lips the bottle is made of diamond and
there's only one thing to shatter
Diamond his voice it's the perfect
family Harmony wow oh this is going to
be a rescue movie this is your second
chance with your brothers Branch it's
not that easy okay you don't have any
siblings that's my point Branch you are
so lucky to have a brother to fight for
I mean if I had a sister it would be so
perfect you are so poppy why did he hide
the sister thing if she were ever in
trouble I would do everything I could to
help her you have an ideal fantasy of
what a sister should be like no that's
me and my sister if there was a brother
that I might do this for and I'm not
saying there is it would be Floyd I'm
not hearing
no you're definitely a poppy oh I don't
know we're going to find them love her
being like no here's how you should feel
and here's what you should do that's
what I do yeah I tell you how to
feel you really think so
what the hell is this
thing this is creepy this is some type
of monster their version of a bus I
guess she likes me yeah she does or
she's marking you as prey can never
quite tell with Rhonda Rhonda the board
is going AB board hi everybody I told
you it was a bus it a bus dang have an
awesome honeymoon thanks poy you L I'm
not sure that I'll ever have a full
wedding but if I do I'm not I don't
think I'll be a bridezilla but that
would have pissed me off of course I
could have
[Music]
waited oh that auto
tune all right I definitely recognize
her voice
definitely I love the commentary these
movies make on the music
industry and genres so what do you want
to know I'm an open book wide open who
are some of your your biggest influences
honestly V's always been my inspiration
oh my gosh H I'd have to go with also me
no never mind that's you now you're
trolling me how do you guys stay the
biggest Superstars Mount rages has ever
known what's your secret secret we don't
have a secret who said we have a secret
it just takes lots of hard work and
loads of natural talent look how like
flexible and bendy they are is it
possible for a troll to have a sibling
that isn't a troll time for a sprit I
barely have any Talent left to give oh
really you don't want to okay that's
fine we'll just kiss our careers goodbye
and focus our efforts on charity a
interesting commentary on people who
feel like hasbin and then the new
electronic era of
music that's more like it they're like
Ursula yeah so is is he going to lose
all his talent or does he get to like
rebuild it why do you have resting Moody
Vibe face no I know we've deserve to be
famous just cuz we want
to it's all going to change as soon as
we have brozone brozone guys these guys
are frustrating I forged a letter
begging for them to come and save you no
you leave my brothers alone oh what a
smart bab yeah that's what I was
thinking how did he write the letter in
the stuck inside this is for all the
love
l a solo
thinking
us I love the music in
[Music]
this ride
that there is more of a Melancholy to
this one this one's made me a little sad
yeah tiny I am no longer a baby and I'm
on a man-sized r of Passage to learn
lesson of life should we be letting a
baby drive baby driver I have procured
my learner permit who is a Doty mcmah
fate are you a n what no no why are you
enough chitchat adulty McMahon face step
on
it are you a Nar is such a great this
movie makes Justin Timberlake look so
good not forgetting about his former
band mates check out your old outfits
puffy jackets hook shell necklaces denim
tuxedos Ranch did you have frosted
tips uh don't forget his perm no wayct
didn't
happen you say Nostalgia leads to
depression it's it's cheering me up
right now we don't need your little
board to find Spruce I got this we can't
find Spruce with this yeah we can all we
have to do is find this Sunset likeing
that optimism poppy seed Branch one word
keeper oh I think he'll marry her look
at this we're never going to find Spruce
with this I bet the sunset doesn't even
exist amazing what a
moment yes
Nails awesome this is the most romantic
honeymoon I've ever been on it is a
night of
surprises this one is uh they they
really up I said it last movie but even
this time around I think visually there
there's so much variety here looks like
clamation so um John who wrot that song
girl I love your love girl I did cool
who wrote um girl you break my heart
girl I did so cool swashbucklers branch
has never written a song I was a baby
what did you want me to write about
diaper rash
Yes W this looks so fun amusement park
ride right like this would be great I
don't know why they haven't tried doing
it yet welcome to V Island where every
day is a vacation so the animation looks
creepy
totally you can't find
[Music]
say this genuinely looks horrifying to
me yeah this is definitely
trippy the sun is so
freaky whoa It's Like
Diamonds
[Music]
looks like little bath bombs they make
the world feel tangible it's your
brothers bitty B
what the last time I saw you you were in
diapers diapers right wet wiie Stop Wet
Willie I am a grownup oh sorry a wet
William wet William we're here because
actually no one's called me Spruce in
years I go by Bruce now I wanted to put
the whole boy band thing thing behind me
now that I'm a dad you can't do that you
can't do that hi honey these are my
brothers oh hello there so nice to
finally meet you she looks like big bird
Daddy Daddy can I have a cookie becoming
a dad was like a like a seismic shift in
my what is happened J B me no biting
Daddy I don't see how any government
stands a
chance they look like Sesame they you
look like Sesame repp yeah like yeah you
do remember our last show don't you if
we practice no we'll be able to nail it
but wouldn't you need the one in the
cage too he'll Sting from inside the
cage yeah I told you Dad wasn't in a
band I was in the band you asked your
mother if I was in a band he was in a
band oh my God gry it prove it prove it
Prove It Go sing with your brothers but
I'm not doing it right now just for
funsies no you're afraid that singing
with your brothers again after all these
years will overwhelm you with emotions
too powerful for you to handle I don't
think you can handle it so I think you
shouldn't do it I think I can handle
singing
song You're her reverse like best clever
I kind of want to dress as her for
Halloween looks so
sweet come on franch prove
it oh that
[Music]
unbelievable
mashups oh he's
[Music]
glowing you're all I ever
needed can't believe this is really
[Music]
happening oh oh this is
cool stay in what's your go to dance
move yeah this one yeah yeah yeah I was
saying
yeah I do
[Applause]
this she joined in she might not get a
sister but she will have brothers but
she does have a sister somehow we don't
know that you should leave now before
you get pink eye save yourself
oh my
God love you abandoned them maybe
Poppy's goingon to have to help sing I
hope so and Poppy's sister this one's
like mainly about other people outside
of Poppy and
Branch you know this is how she did
this no I did that's cute yeah with her
nails
dolly burned me what you said you needed
a way to make your smoothies even fruer
on stage it's a high powerered vacuum
you just pop the grape or strawberry or
blueberry or guava slice and it releases
the fruit's essence through here oh no
they're going to use it for the trolls
tap this button just delicately you know
like once oh
no oh my
god oh no
you said that it was for smoothies
that's horrifying deal with me if you
use too much you'll kill him the that I
tested turned into a prune I don't want
to kill the little guy they're kind of
cute when they're up and about who are
these two voices I don't know go back to
the dark place where we had
nothing please sir I want some more girl
we grew up in these suburbs our parents
were
dentists so she not her singing voice
but she might be Amy Schumer because I
saw her do press for this movie oh okay
that's probably right you're smarter
than I thought now I don't trust you
that's maybe not a rational response I
don't um please don't put me in the cor
now come on we're about to go from stars
to Mega stars have you seen blazing s
not Blazing Saddles uh the ice skating
one with will frell chalad a knce no no
the ice skating one like the Will Arnett
and Amy polar the brother I I think my
answer is yes but that's Amy Schumer not
polar yeah but they were remind me of uh
what is it called but the brother and
sister Dynamic with the Jenna Fisher one
they remind me a lot of them we're going
to make it we've been looking for Clues
to find clay oh I'm sorry the Clue board
you mean my Clue board that I
made we like the Clue board now
what those are just
his no Thunder
[Music]
drawers help us Rhonda she's got the
scent e you see that button
e this is pretty gross Oh you mean the
button that's taking every fiber of my
being not depressed yeah I see it press
it oh hecky yeah that's
trippy oh
[Music]
yes oh my God I love it acid psychedelic
trip this is who produced the music for
this one I feel like they got a really
good producer on this one 1970s right
now at
the
6070s uh hustle design holy crap oh my
God we com got a
third that was excellent that was
excellent are we sure this is where clay
lives DPS is an armadillo bus sniffing
used undies so no we're not sure Yep
this is a really interesting one because
I'm very much aware of like Justin
Timberlake's creative involvement in
this one now you mean like he wanted to
look good I feel like just with the end
it's like this whole Branch storyline is
completely taken over and you could feel
a lot more of these different musical
influences cool they've like really got
more horror with their animation this
time around Who Dares trespass on me S
grounds France what are you
doing listen that's a great visual we're
just here looking for our brother Clay
yo
trolls oh my
gosh who is this my name is Viva it is
so fantastic amazing to see other
trolls she's an isolated troll is she
related a
poppy so fantas amazing is my own
personal word it means um fantastic and
amazing I used to say I'm Astic but then
I was like that's not as good it's got
to be Poppy's sister any troll is
welcome here with us okay papa trolls
lights on oh it's a whole
society God this is sick I love a mini
golf park fries you guys want fries I am
seeing fries Bring Out The Works
milkshakes to celebrate yo this troll is
hot know what I mean you don't see and
go like it's a good looking troll I do
like her
hair these fries are amazing they'
really go great with a
burger what uh veeg vegetarians it's
just that burger sounds a little too
much like uh Perkins oh
oh we call Burgers meat Circle clay hey
what's up man how you man
clay John why do they all hate him well
he seems to be the most naive to how
everyone else feels wait where's Floyd
Floyd's been taken prisoner in Mount
ragis by Superstar singers velvet and
veneer and the only thing powerful
enough to free is the perfect family
Harmony they're slowly becoming in
harmony Lloyd is being held in an
impenetrable Diamond prison yeah that
I'm in oh my God great but we need to
leave from outrageous like now so
siblings in this universe our same skin
tone yeah with po usually how it goes
where' you get that hug time bracelet my
dad gave it to me this is so totally
random but I used to have one just like
it can I see that o it's going to
happen whoa what did you say your name
was again I'm
poppy I'm py
poy is your dad King pee uh yeah
you're you're you're alive you're alive
poppy it's me Viva I'm your sister my my
what your sister your don't woe like you
didn't know clearly it was her sister
yeah I know I'm just saying like I'm
feeling what she's feeling I've always
dreamt of having a sister I was just
saying this wasn't I just saying this
this means we can complain each other's
birthday parties yeah yeah yeah and
weddings yes my best friend Bridget just
had her wedding it's turn out exactly
how she wanted it to
you going to love each other oh my gosh
I'm going to love her I love what you
love is is exactly how she hoped it
would be right now but what happened
that she thought she was dead and like
does she think that the dad I don't
know I definitely recognize her voice
too my
brain I've just been so dazzled by the
animation this time I'm like really
sucked
[Music]
in it's weird that both Poppy and Branch
just is about their siblings at the same
time kind of interesting like almost
feel like too big of a coincidence it's
a kids movie I guess
so
okay so she's a pop star of the genz Gen
I just love the heart of this one a lot
I used to live at the troll tree I was
there when you were born why am I only
learning about you now what happened we
got accidentally
separated and I've lived you ever since
the end she abandoned them doesn't like
to talk about it but she's been here
ever since the night of the great Bergen
attack
oh
this is all tying back to the first
movie not everyone made it out of that
tree they were this close to getting
eaten until Viva and some of the other
trolls fought them off but by
then the tunnels had collapsed the dad
never looked for them I kept screaming
no troll left behind but when I went
back in the tunnels had collapsed that's
when I found viva's hug time bracelet a
via found this old abandoned Bergen golf
course and transformed it into this
troll Utopia trop
I've thought so many times about leaving
you know to look for you and Dad but
it's not safe out there she has such an
adventurous Spirit though I feel so
guilty what do you think I should do I'm
afraid that's our time for today but I
just revealed a major
trauma therapists be keeping a tight 50
they do it's like they have boundaries
with their
patience and neither are you silly
you're never going to leave again what
uh uh wait what was the what was that
last thing oh my God is she a villain
I'll go get Poppy there's no way Bea's
going to let her go what are you talking
about like I said just's got some stuff
going on
man if we don't want to get trapped out
now if we don't want to get
trapped holy crap oh my God this is
becoming fullon horror movie now not
leaving here no matter what because
because it's just not safe out there
you're welcome wait is this about the
burkins Mommy Dearest that's all in the
past yeah right that's hilarious poppy
I'm laughing really hard I'm serious
she's so traumatized Bridget and I do a
million fun things together we talk and
we play games and we sing songs and up
these really bad dances my God I just
got my sister back I'm not going to lose
you but you can't helicopter parent the
situation you
know selfish oh no sorry Viva but we
have to leave I don't want to lose my
brother either no no puppy
wait
aw I want you to
stay I can't do that but you can come
with us I I know you think it's risky
and maybe it is but it'll be worth it a
I
can't sad going have to come back for
her maybe that's not what you you would
want to leave for her yeah just feel
like that would just like leave the
bracelet don't don't leave this book of
my other sister who's the Bergen the
Bergen
Terri I want to be famous but I'm not
going to work for it e this is like so
many Tik tokers I see remember twist our
dances sucked how many fans do you think
we can get making up sucky dances they
are taking so many Jabs at people with
these two he's dead oh man what are we
doing done what do we do you remember
the Goldfish you had as a kid you mean
Sparkles being this close to you next to
a toilet makes me
uncomfortable help me please oh my God
please veneer just let me run past you
you can pretend you never saw me just
because she's your sister doesn't mean
you should let her treat you like
garbage doesn't it no that's a great
listen it's a great doesn't
it sibling or not you deserve to be
treated with kindness and to be around
people who would never try to change the
you that you are I really needed this
movie right now we really make a great
team don't we bro oh no now come
on they better get there
soon I don't know how people feel but I
personally like this more than the last
movie really I like the story more but
it's also speaking to me in a more
personal
way the limit the Stars
it's it it
Blow love how he's got the diaper back
on stop stop time out let's do it again
from the top Spruce I want some smolder
in those eyes this is why people don't
like him we're starting to learn if this
diaper was any smaller I could taste it
oh my
God you love bossing us around just
admit it think I moved to the middle of
nowhere so I didn't have to be in charge
of anyone four little brothers is a lot
of responsibility we can't forget about
Floyd we're here for Floyd let's just
get this done and we can go our separate
ways why does he have to wear the diaper
you didn't think we'd all live together
when this was all over did you roasting
marshmallows oh I'm sorry is that funny
to you that I might want us to actually
be a family again oh that's mean oh
hurts pull over
now don't be a baby branch is Justin Tim
really trying to bring back and SN I
stopped being a baby the day you guys
walked out on me then Grandma Got eaten
and there was no one else to take care
of
me I'm walking out on
you all is so lost right now guys this
is Branch's
bunker he built this for you guys oh my
God it was there in the story all along
every good Trilogy ties back to the
first movie grandma got eeden Grandma
Got eaten all know I feel like I I get
more sucked into the fun of it and you
get sucked into the drama of it I'm
coming with you why bother aren't you
going to leave me eventually anyway
everyone else does I get it man I got a
abandon in issues too I have been by
your side from the moment we met and
you've been by mine let's give each
other some credit here no and I'm not
going
anywhere unless it's with you to save
Floyd
a that's sweet it's the most mature one
of the
three wow chy are they going to merge
the plot lines yeah I don't I don't need
them to I'm totally fine with this no
totally I'm just wondering if they're
going to be able to help at all cuz
that's like her chosen sister whatever
oh true French yeah they're merging but
she finds the book oh she's going to
realize the Bergens are not so bad now
it's feeling like a back to the Tim Bera
[Music]
movie were those golf balls oh no oh
good they're just trolls look how
cute oh no what's happening this is
really creative all the amusement parks
things that they're using to trap them
with quickest way in will be at the roof
the HVAC system o I love how you say
HVAC what
that's
[Laughter]
hot after that oh that is so cool very
cool how do you know which wires to cut
I don't I'm just blasting everything
until something turns off this is the
third Heist thing I've seen in a row
it's so funny my next movie is a heist
movie Greg no is it always l too L St
back L the
he wow you've really grown into that
vest you're a man now the only one who
acknowledges somebody gets
me I told you brozone would show up my
letter works I'm a genius are you sure
you're sure about
this oh my
God hello Floyd Brothers it's so good to
see you oh this is so this movie is
super sad just
love again we're here we're having two
different experiences you get so sucked
into the like the drama of it let's go
autograph some butts oh that's fun I'll
grab my butt marker this one does go
like darker for sure and it's it's less
about like their music numbers yeah I'm
going to need a bob soon oh it looks
like you need a hug oh what if someone's
ever said that to me I'd probably just
like cry right briy loving you is the
best thing that ever happened to me um
would it be weird if we made
out it would be weird if we
[Laughter]
didn't is this
you that's me and my best friend she's
my sister your poppy sister that makes
us best friends
too so you're really not going to eat us
no but I understand the fear if you want
I can open my
mouth TR sted letting yourself feel and
breathe your way through the anxiety
it's called systematic
desensitization or or I let you go and
you promise not to eat us oh that's fine
too I'm loveing so much that was a great
scene but this part makes me sad it's
like every time we go to a happy part I
know you're really getting affected by
it sibling stuff rips me to shreds how's
my aura confident yet grateful to your
teachers and everyone who got you here
tonight that's what I'm going
for she's such a great gaslighter I can
learn a lot from her you know what I
mean SC
you want to succeed you're stealing
Bran's talent because you have none of
your own you big oh you big
phonies okay we need to leave oh here we
go chasing but what was their plan there
I mean there was a public confrontation
yeah but they didn't get back the
bros man I'm trying to get through but
they got no respect for the
blinker no respect for the blinker
can you
wink can you can you do both eyes yeah
good back for back back
[Laughter]
[Music]
back wow this Roose look
nauseating hold her steady
tiny this one's like an action
movie get you guys out of
[Music]
here this feels like Mario Kart it
really
does especially that
part this was like rainbow road but Red
Road I'm gonna learn how to fly
see I can deal with my heartache over
this when we've got good music going on
oh no what do we do let's
hustle yes the best part can you please
drop us off at that boat down there AB
hust not
literally woo yes we would have been
here sooner but we had to make a pickup
first
awesome I'm kind of freaking out a
little bit I love this moment you've got
a Really Brave sister actually I've got
two Really Brave sisters a oh gr this so
touching no gray I love that our stories
complicated who cares if it's not
perfect as long as we're together I
should have come with you I was just did
you just braid my hair yeah learn from
the best oh my gosh it is so fantastic
amazing I love visual gags like that
that was so good yeah all you want in
life is people to show up for you when
you need them I will watch always
Lola that is what I was angling
at whoa shees i k
you I like the scale on this a
lot let's
bro
[Music]
neat oh so inventive I love those but
when they get caught on your hair oh man
that's
annoying you deserve a burn oh they're
going to make everybody sing for the
diamonds to
break Floyd will never make it he's got
nothing left craig Greg we don't have to
be perfect to be in harmony we just have
to be as we are together oh I'm sick
right now
Greg
what
yay some kind of love
it's
of oh here we go my whole body is
[Music]
tingling oh hell yeah oh goost bumps me
too
[Music]
everywhere damn what a
reunion
damn who they're producing on the songs
at this time do you think everybody
realizes their brozone
yeah papy just fan girl this whole
[Music]
time oh the
harmony
Break Free Break
Free
place a perfect
harmony no the talent no no Greg no if
he dies I boycott the
franchise
Floyd come on man wake up no way he's
dead I built The Hideout Floyd except
the Story water
slide their love will resurrect him how
will we
shower no way
yeah we
are FRS wow and we've been literally
torturing little trolls we just wanted
to be famous honestly my sister wanted
to be famous and truly I was too afraid
to stand up to her don't don't just make
her now everyone's just going to blame
her now
but also like he's saying this now too
little too
late I mean Crim what are you doing I
was just saying that I had a change of
heart you also engaged in troll napping
troll torture there we go
fraud fair enough prison it
is w a yay you could do a Good Morning
America interview now how you feeling
happy grateful really sorry that it's
taken me this long to open up to you a
there should be dwarf um
grateful okay oh she's cute they're such
a cute couple just braided your hair it
means she likes you it means I like you
is that Aquafina but the way she was
singing I don't think so but it did
sound like her just there I'm really
glad those 98 Degrees of Separation are
behind us just as long as we're together
hey you guys got to try this
mudo I love the puns so great that new
song is sick branch I knew you had an
have a closing number yeah thanks what
you didn't think broone was the only
band I've ever been in did you please
they you are so in sync that's in sync
this hasn't been in sync the whole time
do we just have an experience where we
thought we were watching in sync the
whole
[Laughter]
time we've done it again
Roxy we had a misle experience for
ourselves twice
[Music]
we will Google who everyone is did they
do that to us on
purpose I mean they wanted us to think
about N Sync the whole time right but
what's this back story of Branch's band
this band he just said you didn't think
you were the only band I know this in
Universe band though better
place EXC see you
excit this does sound like insync I was
having a thought of dang all these
insync guys are good voice actors yeah
I'm thinking that too but they they were
per purposefully wanting us to think
about I was really thinking they're
making like a commentary on queer
representation with Lance Bass and his
earring and like I think they they want
you to think about
them executive music I mean I think
Justin Timber like always has been but I
feel like he was way more involved this
time yeah well this was the first time
the story was about him right like where
he's the lead yeah I have a small
proposal will you join the band of
course I will I thought you would never
ask you know me too well now get up here
and sing with
[Laughter]
us this is my dream
life my dream life is amazing feeling
Anna Kendrick's still top bilding
though digs whoa which one was Andrew
what Amy Shimmer you got that right okay
yeah I saw her do something for
it with and sync
okay we'll look it up Camila Cabo that's
who that voice was yep that's that must
be the sister zosa Mammoth what who is
she Christopher mint plaz what did you
what's
happening
damn darn
dang okay you think there's gonna be a
post
credit I there might be do you think so
well I'm kind of hoping for some kind of
reconciliation between Poppy's sister
and
Dad uh it seems like they made up pretty
fast like forgiveness runs quick in this
franchise some kind of EX if you're
Branch yeah do do you know if this is
the last trolls movie I doubt it I feel
like they do like 10 of these oh yeah no
the DreamWorks they they milk their
movies for as long as possible okay so
throughout unless you're How to Train
Your Dragon for the whole movie you kept
saying that you liked this better than
the second one do you feel that way
right
now uh overall yeah I I there are things
I I prefer about the second one I feel
like we have very different experiences
watching this movie Greg you could say
that about literally any movie that ever
existed with me and
you that's not true I just feel like
sometime the things that you think are
funny are the things that I think are
depressing and the things that I think
are funny are the things that you think
are sad you get you get so caught up in
like the you get very empathe so the
naos was good that was a lot of fun and
then I got to drive the van that was
cool so then we got locked in mini golf
of course and there was a giant clown
head that started talking to us this is
the reconciliation you're were hoping
for but yeah I'm enjoying the journey
I'm enjoying the journey I'm growing I'm
developing he's in therapy how much I
owe you this is covered by insurance
right no I'm out of
network gosh therapist I feel you I feel
you there man before I hear the rest of
your this is also commentary on
insurances and mental health I agree
with it's crazy um but you know
everybody's got to get paid wait
everyone be quiet how quick we remember
everyone
is wow okay via was camil Crim velvet
was Amy Schumer wow is Andrew reyell who
was the one who played the brother um to
Velvet okay that is a very fascinating
oh actual dance choreography so this was
absolutely not in sync for the entire
movie oh yeah no if there's one thing we
can confirm is that we had a very
different experience from everyone else
who watched this movie movie can confirm
wrong wrong wrong and wrong we we just
watched orph first kill and the entire
time we were convinced that they shot
that movie two years later and said it
was actually 13 years later we just stop
thinking any this entire time we were
like oh wow yeah in this movie the
entire time you think people were
shouting at us at home I I I was like
that's obviously Lance Bass Greg it
sounds like him right fo and I just do
this to create engagement in the
comments you know we actually knew the
whole time we just we just wanted you to
type away go ahead and troll us and by
the way we deserve to be trolled for
this one if you're listening on Apple or
Spotify go ahead and leave us that five
stars don't troll us over there give us
that good comment yeah I remember I want
to see all the nice things they have to
say about us because we banned together
we ban together and we get rated five
stars well for those who are listening
we watched trolls band together and we
thought N Sync was the cast the entire
time yeah we did it did happen it it
drastically affected my viewing
experience because the entire time I was
going man the creative control Justin
Timberlake must have had over this one
in a while but it still had to be a
commentary on that otherwise they
wouldn't they didn't want us to be
thinking like that they wouldn't have
had been five band members oh yeah no
everything he could had three brothers
the commentary making it about branch
and Justin Timberlake and his backstory
with being part of NSYNC like yeah the
the entire time they want you to think
about it did you have favorite brother I
mean Floyd yeah easily the best one I
like Floyd too he was good but they're
all different and cool I did kind of
miss this being Poppy's story oh of
course sure women's opinion here I
needed a male story yeah it's a good
point to identify with yeah yeah I feel
like they should take the franchise in a
male driven Direction I do love sister
stuff though oh I love sibling stuff
this story it did affect me okay go back
for a second though so you were saying
about this compared to the first one
second one you talk I want to hear you
talk but you were in the middle of a
thought before I can remember my thought
okay I want to hear it um but I'd rather
listen to
you why because I want to be
respectful you don't want to troll me no
I want to be respectful wa I just want
to know whether you like this one better
or worse than the second one the first
one I would rank this second however I
do think there are things that uh I
understand so one3 two yeah but I in
terms of like a a movie um but I do
think the second one undoubtedly gives
you more of what you probably want from
a trolls movie like that one delivers
more on the goods it's more fun it's
poppy story and and there there's a
direction about this one that this the
story itself just kind of spoke a little
bit more to me and I do intentionally
keep personal life stuff uh out of
videos for for for my reasoning um but I
know in this I said you and I both have
siblings and you went silent yeah well
no I love my siblings uh but we have
never mind we have no siblings we have
different
we have different um Dynamics chemistry
and Dynamics with with our siblings and
um Back stories with our siblings and so
yeah like there are things for branch
that I'm like I really I really get this
like there's so much about like
obviously I don't have like the same
backstory as Bren but there the the
emotional undertones and like the
uncomfortability and you know wanting to
be close but feeling like you're kind of
like shelf in you don't really know how
to be yourself like there's so so much
about it that I really identify with and
being a younger sibling too uh so yeah
like and I like how it had like
different dynamics of of sibling stuff
where the villains are um you know like
you have an older sister sibling Dynamic
but it's it's so much about like even
though you have family it's also about
forming your own identity outside of
your family as well but also knowing how
to be supportive on that path to
like I thought there was actually a lot
of cool nuan things a lot of times there
is this like Pixar kind of does this
thing nowadays uh with a lot of their
Disney I hear in general kind of this
thing with their stories of like y don't
just live under the thumb of your
parents like there's a lot of that kind
of messaging happening and I get what
they're trying to do and I thought this
actually had a more nuanced version of
that in and to a certain extent by
saying don't just live under the thumb
of your sibling uh well there was I mean
that was that clearly for the villains
but in terms of like just the overall
Dynamics especially for the boy band
members and branch of yeah you have to
like it's like sunshine in my ear
holes that's a line right there that's
what she said um yeah jez but you don't
like sunshine in your it's a very
suggest it's a really weird line um I
don't really like anything in my ear
holes no neither do I uh except when I'm
clearing out my ear wax I got one of
those ear wax cameras oh you got one of
those
uh yeah because I get like a lot of yeah
I think it's great yeah but are you
scared that you're going to hurt
yourself I want to buy one of those uh
no it's actually pretty easy it is like
uncom you get used to it but the when
you first start using it it is like oh
my God am I damaging my ear um I mean I
should always go to a professional but I
want to get one of those yeah they're
great they're actually like pretty
affordable my birthday is July 13th yeah
sure um you should treat yourself by
buying
yourself what a present for somebody
here here uh unprompted I got you I just
noticed something about your
uh whenever we're hanging out your
hair's tied up uh what's up with the
trolls your wag we don't know just who's
to say I I totally get what you're
saying though like I love the the Pixar
uh don't get out of your parents you
know you can be your own person thing
but I do think that the trolls movies
have had very strong messages for each
movie right and so it is hard for me to
rank them it is really based on sound
but like personal preference and and
relation to characters right because the
last one being music is for everyone
don't judge it you know um your thing
isn't better don't be the keeper of
things enjoy every you that kind of the
messaging behind that versus this one
which is about the power of siblings and
I do love that Justin Timber that branch
and all of his siblings regardless of
the fact that they were no longer close
they had seen each other in a long time
every single one of of the siblings when
they found out that one of them needed
their help they all said yeah let's go
and I think that is the the beautiful
message and power family that it should
be hopefully if you do have uh that
family bond where it's like it might not
be your favorite person there might be a
lot of past issues it there might have
been things that went down you might not
have talked to somebody in a while there
might be whatever backstory there is but
if somebody needs you that's your
sibling and and that's what I hope for
all siblings you know of course you hope
more than that for siblings you hope
that they can be the best and best of
friends and and luckily I have an
amazing relationship with my siblings to
be able to experience that but at the
bare minimum I think that what you hope
for for siblings is that when somebody
needs you you come running right and
that's what we did see here and even
with the poppy storyline with was it Pia
Mia teia what was what was her sister's
name
Shia Z I don't know I felt like it was
an I uh don't remember what it was but
with her sibling the hot one camil Cabo
uh the hot can't be calling her the hot
one you're the hot sister aren't you you
know there was that at first poppy asks
for her and she says I can't come with
you and that was out of fear and we see
that was the wrong choice right like you
don't want to not go somewhere out of
fear you got to show up for your loved
ones when especially when they're asking
and so then she does make that choice so
you're able to kind of see both sides of
it anyway sibling stuff really gets to
me so sounds like you really didn't like
this movie really no I'm just joking
you're speaking with such like a a
fervor about the message and yeah just
had a lot of meaning to me about
siblings the whole movie was about
siblings right it was about the sibling
Dynamic of the uh pop stars it was about
the sibling Dynamic of Poppy and her
sister I also love that when poppy got
there sometimes we know these movies
harp on like how did we get to this
point where a strange well do are we
okay I'm so mad at you if sometimes
instead of wasting time just jump in if
you want a relationship with somebody
just eff and jump into it yeah so I and
I did like that we didn't harp too long
on that but just saying that it was all
about siblings about the brothers it was
about the sisters and it was about the
pop stars and we saw very different
sibling Dynamics throughout and what we
saw is what works best is when you
support each other yeah it was nice I
mean neither I I appreciate at this
movie was trying to take a more mature
Direction I think this the story itself
is stronger the things that were kind of
missing for me were um like when the
music was there it's it's always great
like I was I it's a weird at um it's a
weird uh dual feeling I have about the
the music in this movie because when
it's there it's like I was so impressed
with how they executed the songs here I
kept out saying out loud like who
produced The Music In this one because
this was so well done um and it felt
different like it felt like the the
other
ones I don't want to downside cuz I
thought they were great in the other
ones too uh but they they did feel more
like yeah the trolls remix version of
them and this felt like I could just
listen I I would put this on and just
listen to it you know you could say the
same thing about the other ones but to
me that there was something that felt
more I don't know like a like a a record
produced version of it at I really don't
want that to sound like I'm I'm sliding
the other ones the other ones I get what
you're saying cuz I mean I I can't stop
the feeling from the first I listen to
that still like I love I found that
through the movie and I still listen to
it um but overall like this the tunes
here were just you haven't heard that
song Until the movie I don't think I
might have heard it before but I don't
think I
really listen to it until the movie and
and um yeah so
but it's it the music is such a part of
the world and I and weirdly even though
it was about getting the band back
together and all that stuff I didn't
feel like I kind of feel like it uh the
musical side of it was not as prevalent
as the other ones were is prevalent
prevalent um I think so are are those
two different
things that might just be the
pronunciation yeah I'm not sure do you
kind of get what I mean though about
what I'm saying not I don't know I'm not
asking you to agree I'm just saying you
get what I'm saying yeah I do I do get
what you're saying it's can't quite
pinpoint why though something for me
though was that this movie was much
darker and more upsetting to me so I so
desperately needed the music in this one
that I'm not even judging the quality or
the differences between the last one and
this one I just needed it you know like
I was like give me that mash up because
I'm sad right now I guess I just I
didn't succumb to the drama as much as
like I I was really upset the heartfelt
stuff I was I got like Prett I got I got
I cried a little bit too at one point
like I got but but it was more when I'm
like touched by something you would get
caught up in the harrowing side of
something and I would be really touched
by something whereas you would be like
this is miserable experience with
they're going through and I never quite
got there with the movie whereas you
would wait before you go anywhere you
know what's interesting is that the the
uh Lo line of poppy discovers that
Branch was once part of the boy band
brozone and it's like that's interesting
or the summary because that's what IMDb
does there the summary right poppy
discovers and they wanted the first
thing it's Poppy's Discovery and it's
like this really wasn't about poppy
discovering she is fully relegated to a
supporting character like like let like
Viva that was camil Cabo's name it's not
even really uh ohiv it's easy I said Mia
Jesus Christ it's not even that uh uh uh
like Branch was more of an important
supporting
character like you could really there is
a version where you could have done this
movie without poppy yeah like I like her
storyline and I like how you got a
different Dynamic again of like the
siblings who reunite who meet each other
for the first time and it is just we
just love each other so much I thought
that was so it was so funny to me
because um yeah would Branch you you
would expect normally you would kind of
get a bit of like wait who are you and
you kind of go through the drama of that
but I love how it was just a joyous
experience and you don't actually see
that a lot in movies yeah I can't
believe that was Eric Andre as John Dory
that's
wild that makes sense kid cudy was Clay
which one was Clay you know the one with
big hair that's the thing is like I
don't I don't personally feel like their
personalities were distinct
enough I kind of like I I don't know I
got might push back as I me one was
obviously more bossy and then you got
Floyd who was like was Kay the one with
the big hair that flowed backwards or
was Clay the
one I'm not sure who had the hair like
this or like this okay there's only one
who was a little bit forgettable to me
it was the guy who ran the restaurant
with the with the giraffe wife that the
one who you were just naming but the the
one who was with was that clay I might
have been the one was with po Spruce was
Bruce yeah Floyd we know John dor we
know yeah Spruce I thought he was
actually a little
forgettable Spruce was Bruce yeah who
playso who's Floyd he was great let's
look him up Troy savan yeah you know him
I do I don't know him I have no idea who
this guy is scroll
down scroll down trying scrolly scrolly
holy I mean he was in a movie I saw like
13 years ago the idol that's how I know
him Idol the idol you know that big um
HBO show that got's daughter yeah I
actually thought she was good in it
nobody else did okay Christopher wait
scroll down Christopher M's PL was all
them King gristle oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yep yep yep yep yep they do
good a good job Anderson Pac was in this
too wow a lot of a lot of really cool
voices a lot of great music a lot of
good sibling
stuff just to sum it up you would still
rank this
third you be honest no no I I might be
with you where it's 132 usually lie on
camera you you're known to be a liar
you're a trolly poly oi today huh you're
I I keep saying I'm going to be sweet
and sincerer than I and then you can't I
I'm trying to commit commit to the bit
Yeah the bit of being
nice makes it not
sincere if you were control design
yourself for a second what's your skin
what's your hair okay my skin would
1,00% be purple I would be purple my
hair would be cornrow because you don't
see any with cornrow color uh they would
be uh green cornrow I'd get a grill I'd
have a tattoo that says damaged on my
forehead oh my God and then I would have
a lot of
tattoos why are you the Joker um Joker
doesn't have cornrows
and and then I would also damage green
hair I would also have angel wings on my
back I get angel wings could you fly it
uh yes I'd be able to spr Wings and my
pants would be those painted pants that
when people go to the gym and they do
like Tik toks be like hey I'm actually
wearing pants at the gym but they're
just a spray on pants you know what I'm
talking about no but they're not
actually pants are you kidding no it's a
real thing that people do they like
spray the pant like they spray it to
look like they have have pants on but
it's really just like a spray on thing
where is their wee
we uh in their underwear usually so
they're wearing underwear with spray
paint over it
yeah what the are you making this out no
it's a real
thing if I was making it up I I I would
sell that idea and become like really
rich why would you sell that who would
buy that that's so weird influencers by
that who influences the influencers I
know right uh what would your what would
your troll look like was that not a
perfect transition for you to talk about
our show it's so late in the video no
one's going to care what what was the
what was the what would your troll look
like um have we seen any yellow trolls
no maybe yellow and
gold spray paint pants my dude no no
spray paint uh what is it called
leggings I literally saw this one girl
she's like an influencer girl and she
went to the gym and then she got kicked
out because she would did a whole it was
the whole thing was obviously set up so
she could get kicked out where like a
guy was complaining being like you're
obviously not wearing pants this is
inappropriate and she's like these are
pants and it's like but he knew what
they were that it's like it's a spray on
design like it's a real thing I think we
should go go yeah I think we're done no
I'm telling you I think we're good I
think I'm GNA milk I'm gon to bleed your
your run time two hours exactly I think
uh you've trolled me enough yeah I think
I I think I do go 132 still I think I go
132 but I did like two a lot I've liked
all of them I don't know where they go
from here I I like the new character of
Viva I would like to explore their
relationship I want to go back to
focusing on puppy puppy I want to know
about Poppy's dad and why he never
looked for the daughter those are my
thoughts they do I think the one thing
is that yeah well I'll end with this I I
feel like the
movie was at at times at a bit of a I
didn't really like the villains honestly
in the movie um I like the idea of they
were really upsetting I like the concept
of the villains but I don't like that I
thought they were kind of like dull and
annoying they were frustrating but not
not in a complimentary way like I like
the commentary they had that was like
poking fun at this type of musician that
exists nowadays that becomes famous via
social media I I get it there's no way
that Amy Schumer's singing voice right
probably not like whose voice was that
they could have um I have no idea it's
very good um but I do think this
particular one while I would rank it
above two I do feel like at times the
storytelling becomes a also the
animation I thought it was Exquisite uh
is a bit at odds where they want to kind
of go a little bit more with the drama
like a Pixar movie or like some of their
other DreamWorks films where that that
do take the time to go a little bit more
bold with their Dr drama and
characterization but then they go but
we're the trolls franchise so we got to
like uh move past this a little quicker
and uh you know yeah when I felt that
they were actually wanting to to dive in
more to that uh uh emotional stuff so
that's the only thing I think it's
possible if I saw two third that I would
like two better I don't know I'm going
back and forth in my head over and over
can you put your leg behind your head
right now are you able to I don't know I
am in jeans let's try it
I don't know I'll help you I didn't even
I don't know why my listen th this thing
so I was using this the rolly thing on
the ground and at some point one of your
cats went inside so I couldn't roll and
so I my my legs like was hovering them
and then they got we got to get out of
here thank you so much to our favorite
trolls no you guys aren't trolls you're
Rejects and that's what makes you the
best so band together leave a comment
let us know what you thought and we'll
see you for
what are we doing next let us know what
we're doing next terrifier what is that
oh it's a kids movie about a clown
really yeah called terrifier yeah that's
the give away that I've been messing
with you see you for
terrifier Troll's
[Music]
audience